you
everybody's ready to go 4500 plus
right
let's give it give it your best that's
all we could do current lineup here for
Team chest Network
50
there we go
through more if we could here we go for
kickoff 5 4 3 2 & 0
let's do it
ka star
we see our team here
he's debating on whether or not to
preserve me he should resort me he's
very he's very speedy and
I know berserk
mr. ka star Congrats by the way
now a GM
you
now let's go for a fika dough
side of my style
we'll do it
and I am recently turned Geum
and try and chip away at the d4 square
if we can
I'm playing this recently with some say
access
so
I like throwing the night on a six he
can be a great bug I'll pick one of
these two too
to chop I don't know
sometimes you can see a night reposition
and I'm immediately going for this so f3
f4
No
ah
[Music]
yeah that seems a little weird be honest
my queen with the knight on a six of
preventing b4 which is much further away
now because the night is in the way
Knight b5 there isn't this threat so my
clean this is one of my ideas
Genaro square bishops I want to keep
this tension I also want to be in a spot
to just recapture
I think white has abandoned
- okay so that's another that's another
interesting approach hunting with f4 so
given up on the queenside play I don't
know if I want to push yet because this
night
it's not such a great piece and I'd be
inviting it to a very good square if I
push so just bring a rook over
now let's just centralize how bad can
centralizing be they're offering a clean
exchange
Oh
let's say let's just keep the Queens on
for a little bit
night there
[Music]
no maybe maybe hinting at rook to g8
someday
oh I could have considered a kick that
night let me jump in now oh I just
dropped this pawn that's a really big
pond to drop I have this
yeah it's a really big pond to drop oh
well
here would have been met with queen here
and I'm not winning the exchange you got
to keep the clean zone take here and
have it forever night
I don't know I could still replace it I
don't know let's see
night here
I don't know
I guess I'll be taking with the bishop
if pawn takes
my intention was really to take with the
night
very complex beginning
you
let's go here
Oh
push
I have to defend this pawn
but here
like my king is gonna need some air
take care first
not a fun piece to part with
you
mm-hmm
okay
I don't know how good - Maya
go here
it's scary I want to try and get it f4
slight edge on the clock
Broca's maybe trapped
I taken to King
you
pressure here
you
scary
you
you
you
should be winning
I don't know I didn't exchange there
you
yay whoo that also took forever
very complicated lot of
hmm
what to say a lot of
lunders it felt so long away
very
I was really just blunder e5
[Music]
let's go here
let's connect Knights
all right so they parted ways with the
dark square bishop what a baby step it
let's see this before I play that play a
little slow stay flexible re I'm more
inclined to throw a pawn in the center
now
let's change the structure
spawn
be a developer
hmm
just go one step for now behind on the
clock let's go to see if I could rattle
the clean position nope
let's go all in
sort of
[Music]
I don't know that's kind of a just make
a moving fast
put my bishop on a defended square rules
out f3 and I'm changing plans I'm being
more aggressive with my H pawn
let's go H pun
and it'll take
I do something else at my LightSquared
Bishop let's let's go here excuse me
didn't see that you guys have to play
some defense I have night here
what's that night even doing
not sure
where's that night going I'm eyeing up
Bishop here and one day if I could get a
queen on h3 if they take I'd be happy
think they should leave it sitting don't
budge
I'm hitting the rook I'm just realizing
I'm hitting the brook
I don't know if it's a great
inconvenience
trade
pressure on the night
maybe h3 but I'm unprepared to sack
maybe
oh I could take and then give a check
this check first
and then here
Kings in after run I don't know how I
didn't see that much sooner
you know this square get this pawn and
then promote and this attack is too slow
over here looks like a ridiculous piece
on a7 but it serves a
also this would have been pretty strong
threatening me threatening this I guess
will collect a pond hit the night or
just win the night next time win a free
night next time we check that might be
pretty good and let's go here first
increase the pressure
I think now they're taking the pond
they could be in some big trouble
not
we got stuff like this
uh where's that night going gonna be
scary
let's give a check
get this wreck plane
night here Queen exchange than this and
they win this pawn oh not right
- what we do it like this
I don't like the technique at all I
should be
what I'm doing here
rook here and then Bishop takes g6 as an
idea
Knight takes pawn is also an idea
let's support my night
now we could do this
the rock
let's keep the night around the king
when another pond
Jax
earning me
this will do like this push pawns
stop activity
keep pushing keep pushing push right
throughout I knew my rook this point but
I'll still save them
we have a choke
take care
take here
no stalemates
just in case we'll give that pawn a move
you
together we'll give that punim of as
well
avoid the stalemate stuff okay we got a
couple W's in there
a tough turnout sincerity rules is
currently the the pack leader for the
team here Kress book is in there at
first chatroom no okay oh I could see it
right here who's who's doing what
let's see if we could get a four
look at 11 points is a what's the what's
the tournament that's the team
tournament
numbers we don't have that
take and play in the center
I'll take with the Queen
not just when this guy I'm gonna go I go
hunting
it's my only safe Square now they could
ruin my structure but now with the you
know oops excuse me hit my mic there
with
you
let's let's go here if my opponent gives
up their dark square bishop when they
don't have a when they have these big
holes around
it's a problemo most likely
[Music]
just want to put my knight on better
square or go clean side
getting here oof upon and the exchange
you
grab some space
where's that night headed
we'll keep going this is a very good
guardian for the queenside
knight on c3
centralize and push through let's
babysit an unprotected night first
we've also jumped in
let's push here first flush that Bishop
back and now go here
the bishop
and take it
a Pinter Oni not take advantage put my
opponent in a pin
and just win the bishop
so let's see
um I really want to see the tournament
standings not there
you
I should have maybe thrown the other
captured with the other up there
first
yes we could still try for it
put pressure on something along the way
maybe one threat pawn here it's me
this is the only tribe now it's forced
mate
that's me all right
Kress book is in first 279 248 it
happened so fast
let's go with e4
a Sicilian let's play Bishop to b5
all right now we're going to take and
then
try and be a pest something long-term
I'm looking looking early long-term
yeah I think I've already
missplay that let's play in the center
prepare to take with the Queen and have
my queen around to defend this pawn
then take and then exchange Queens
oh I'm also hitting the rook you know
that's that's useful I guess I'm going
to take care exchange Queens throw the
knight in the center they're going to
need to cover this otherwise this rook
and have a very tough time I think he's
as close to having a tough time
[Music]
oof
and was a Miss alright they resigned
they had a blind spot there for a second
try and keep a streak going
and get and get a four here so I'm
forgetting can see the team I'm I'm
going against here representative of
chess media
they've been in there before
FM opponent for
I'm playing this guy
let's break this pin they may intensify
pressure up hey they're hitting my
Bishop take here I'm going to take care
I know I could recapture and develop a
bishop but I like this night
should I be aggressive I'm going to same
um let's go opposite the Queen first and
then maybe be aggressive
I'm gonna say yeah let's go here before
castles all right so they're allowing
they're allowing e5 let's get castles in
that was a little all right now I'm
gonna go here and I'm prepared to take
the knight when he jumps in see how they
recapture you know they could go there I
don't have any great discoveries were my
knight could go here follow up I'm not
seeing it now let's drift my knight over
towards the Kings side
and
and it's going to be tricky and it's
gonna be tricky I'm I think I'm just a
little too slow here
yeah I'm not liking my position
how can i stir up some trouble
ever played b3 Bishop AIDS freeze gonna
hurt me I feel like I want to abandon
[Music]
abandon control the beef I'll try and
organize my pieces I think I don't have
to go all in
they have to go all in f4 very dangerous
yet we're going I said eh I'm gonna have
to say B I just have to go for it do I
care about my a pawn maybe I do let's
save them
okay they're offering a queen exchange
normally I'm a fan my knight actually
serves a pretty good role here and
there's lining up Bishop there you got a
point
let's hold my ground here
Bishop there Queen d2 I won't be able to
recapture at the rook I need my clean
defending deform way down on the clock
it's held together maybe by a thread
maybe
this work over here my lights in a pin
clean here
and they have yep yep yep yep
you
rook there's probably a move yadus
twinning
yeah
little back rank stuff maybe
oh it's wits check as well yeah I was
thinking if I could have two moves in a
row maybe play a few more moves I guess
oh no am I ever able to control this
square I doubt it
you
yeah I don't know how to weave some me
out there mm-hmm
'if I push well not not well timed I
guess with that one
my night was a little too clumsy like
that pressure on d4 if I could have that
structure in my night on a different
square I think there's a different I
think the the result kind of it can be
different
yeah
my night he felt a little little clumsy
within that structure is what I'm so
what I'm trying to say
I guess we're going to play against the
hanging pawn structure
this guy feels like he's playing much
better than his rating
let's keep pressure here I want to stop
this advance
try to
I guess here here and then thar
okay that felt a little too slow so that
this should be a problem
d6 I said if you have to do that it's a
problem I think I'm not not just winning
upon I think it's more than that and
hitting a lot of stuff now c5
let's invite the knight in there to
recapture he's more than he's more
invasive than a bishop would be on c5
also this forward
is forward mentality how about I take
the night and then play e5
by winning a piece there think I am my
pawn goes into pac-man
here bishop rook takes Bishop takes
Bishop I take the knight they could take
my rook I recapture and I'm on I'm on
both bishops at the end of this and they
could only save one maybe Bishop here
I might have been the way to save the
peace
as it is now I am I'm up something
I didn't like that move
jump in there
and I had my flight square let's get a
little aggressive now target the a pawn
F pawn
I'm just losing the peace back
not a fan of how I played these last few
moves
not at all
all right can I just save my night can I
find some coordination and since crazy
very poor technique
very poor
all right let's go here where you're a
multi-purpose piece
we can take its with check
let's just put the night on a
here square so you don't drop them
go here
knock out this palm
a loud Pelican is playing for the crest
book okay
resigned crest book is up there
five were in there with 309 next
opponent your let's go let's make a move
so it's D for D for C for nimzo-indian
Queens Indian
let's go @d v upon sach
trying to be like alpha zero is all no
no no this is the mope silly
I opted out that softened up f5 square
that'll take
in right now and look one day for an e
5e 45 maybe I should have done that
before castles anyhow
here here queen on g4
pawn on e5
that nights very good though
maybe I've miss plated okay I think this
was important though that I put pressure
this these guys don't get rolling so
easily
bishop up to
we don't know
[Music]
let's play with the h-bomb
I still play with the h-bomb
well let's get the Queen developed this
night better not go too far got a mate
threat so he has a big responsibility
I'm prepared
okay what was I prepared for
let's put my bishop right here can't
take yet and even when it does become a
possible move
I'm prepared to just take with my Jeep
on actually
let's go here there's also these tricks
maybe in the air if that Queen is
unprotected huh really feels close to
like there's a tactic can I invite this
night into the mix my pieces are
swarming near the king now taking
advantage of a pin the night diving in
their Sun there's something here there's
got to be something here
all right let's say like a jump here
actually what's wrong with
get that dark square bishop
guess around this square the bishop the
rook - seven so it's not
so easy to defend I thought about this
plan but I don't like that the night
could take would check and simplify
these nights both competing for this
square whoa
huh
it could take here
and then take the rook
I'm gonna take care first
and then here and I'm on a lot of stuff
right now
and let's that's a big pond a very big
pond
is passed
get rolling with them right now let's go
upon working - oh I should play this
then I have connected passers I don't
care that they went upon I want these
guys to roll
[Music]
let's go here and then king f2
they're opposite
got here first I'm running into fork
maybe I don't care about that though
was helpful
feel like I wanna
sacrifice something right here
down on the clock just remove something
all right
King here you know just try
bishop
bishop here Bishop on this Square and
then King out for okay they're taking
you got to get rid of that put my king
on f5 and it's a win
yep I get here just in time I could kick
the King back as well
yeah these pawns are too much it's flush
them back first
or g7 even funny ways to do it
passer for a while but
they're probably a lot of tactics missed
in that middle game
my kingside got flooded with a lot of
white minor pieces or the queenside
our King Kings I got flooded
threatening male 1 alright they resigned
uh where are we at I can't believe a
half hour already passed that's crazy
time flies I don't know I want to know
man I still want to know and I don't
know where we're at team standing wise
we have our team leaders there's the
cable box cable box got first four for
the team
in one of the streamers battle
let's see space
just a little space is all
we're gonna defend here with still an
eye on a dark square bishop exchange now
before to get before black can get
moving with b5 the Queen's gonna have to
take another step she does let's uh
let's kind of rule out the B 5 square b5
push and centralize like this
a central break and then stop Bishop g4
I guess we go for this exchange now
um
[Music]
I'm going to take here first if I take
here the night's going to recapture and
then be the one to recapture on f5 so
let's run it like this
let's take here
and what I want to do now
is remove this guy and put a knight here
and basically win think
so
I'm gonna go here first if I did this
right away there's a tactic on H 3 and
then F 3 Falls so I think I could afford
this lower approach this one tempo with
Queen e3
should probably duck this exchange okay
so now this is huge I mean once he's
there he's he's he's hitting a lot
so then the queenside is really
underdeveloped okay so I'm winning the
exchange
Oh winning a full rook maybe a mouse
slip they want to King g8 alright
they're designed how to W let's see 515
those guys are
are way up there let's try
a Sicilian I
[Music]
let's take
and play d5
enter something maybe a little different
they're in the tank so they paused a
little bit
just a bit
and have to take some steps to
to make sure d5 doesn't get in there a
check with the bishop so this is
normally a very aggressive piece
pointing at my king but it had a
different idea I guess and now I'm going
to put my bishop here I'm going to focus
on reorganize reorganizing my Queen side
pieces first
you
I guess we're gonna leave my knight
right here if you want to take my bishop
you get the bishop pair
but
you would be inviting my night forward
so Oh No
let's see Queen Queen b3 concerns me
some all right no Queen b3 maybe Queen
b3 I take here then
get a little messy clean be three takes
takes takes takes I get this you get
something a night or my bishop all right
so what do I want to focus on this
square no I take with the Queen I'm on
the bishop
that push-up is a killer almost feel
like I need to take this bishop out
before
I want to be able to have this maybe in
some situation where they take on b7
they could ruin my structure we end up
having this disjointed battle
between isolated ponds which one is
weaker I'm not sure so right now I could
take on d4 and I think I'm going to and
I guess we're gonna enter these
complications and I always have this
check if they take my night get the
Queen Bishop takes b7 maybe takes a 6 I
have a very active rook maybe 90 to
check and some lines I'm going to find
out
let's be alert the alert to pieces that
are unprotected there are a lot of them
Queen here can be a move maybe but my
night is hanging my queen starts to have
this indirect defense of the night
so it's wild it's nice to be up slightly
on the clock
I almost feel like no that's not a move
I guess we're gonna just back off defend
the threat I'm on this and this now that
the night is no longer defending a two
so it's balanced
like my position I like my night here I
wouldn't mind having the dark square
bishop around that means my knight could
really rely upon the d4 square
Bishop III Knight of five
hey you're gonna get some exchanges both
of us still need a flight square I have
a couple checks for the night let's keep
an eye on those this Bishop is
unprotected
let's support my knight and hit the
bishop for starters find a new square
bishop
and how about we go here just keep some
pressure
tricks if they attack my rook maybe this
with another idea to have a discovery
and defend my Queens
carrying her weight
yeah so like right now I think this is
the the trick
also the there's this responsibility
that the bishop has otherwise 92
my queen is gluing everything together
in this position my opponent's way down
on the clock this night is enormous
neither rook is playing for white
and mine are so is this not winning the
bishop believe it is no way for the
Queen to move
and defend the bish
they resigned okay sir max let's try
four against sir max
we're in Tinh entering in aliens defense
alright Bishop to g4 let's let's go here
I've been playing this line the mixed
results with some pawn sacrifice
I could go here first now let's just
take prepare to pin a night
in fact I think I want to go
I want to do
let's put some pressure on this night
and
also have this in mind
okay here
here here I have this heading the knight
defending here I just want to be able to
castle have my wreck on the e1 if I
could maintain this pawn be happy
what are they threatening exactly I
could take here actually don't mind how
am I doing this
just castle
so we have an imbalance let's let's put
the knight in the center
a central inbounds okay they're just
throwing the knight in the center why
not you know keep pressure on something
maybe I'm ready to kick the Queen away
and win the night Bishop c5 defends but
it's vulnerable there are checks I had a
night in the last game on d4 so it can
be a pest for sure
I also have an f5 check if the knight
goes too far all right and I feel like I
want to go here and then yeah yeah let's
go here I mean they have a knight move
okay if I take here we check and then
play g3
what am I missing
in the Queen move and defend the night
yes it can how did I miss that
oh man okay and I have to take that
Queen well that was a really big miss I
missed that Queenie for was there
game continues still bounce materialize
but I do not like my position
I think this pond will just fall too
maybe
maybe I put up a little bit of
resistance the play rookie one not even
threatening to get that pawn because my
back rank
that check I don't know was I really
scared of that check scared
I guess we'll go with this one
all right I can't I have to just give up
a pawn I have to make sure I have some
activity for my ROK's it's just how it
is
now
is here
and start a little maybe maybe I could
have started with rook to have four
you
rook F rook here is not a bother yeah I
think that there's gonna be a waste of
tempo no I wanna
want to kind of promote my pond here
okay now is this not winning upon
feel like I'm getting somewhere
possibilities to maybe get some pigs
there's rook wouldn't be around to
defend c7 if I could put two Brooks here
in a timely way
so this takes takes check and then rook
here
and he's there in time okay is it going
for that but suppose I baby said let's
babysit and go hunting grab this pawn
and bolt
we're going to get these two in the
meantime
or that one that one works too
you
yeah gotta go
take here get this others rook here to
defend
I'm threatening mate hang on threatening
me
no not easy to defend not easy to defend
just realizing that now he's gotta go
there
I'm threatening mate again and getting
the rook just seeing that this is
winning
there's no time to defend the king and
the rook
whoo pigs on the seventh pigs on the 8th
in that one
okay let's keep okay call this 90
playing for a GAD Raiders team I keep
not looking at
not looking at
whoo-hoo I'm playing against
let's let's be progressive I've played
this too much on on c6 let's be a little
more aggressive I guess
let's back off and it take
um let's go like this it seems weird but
I'll give it a go
yeah they could chop I don't not really
a fan of having two pawns here now so
the knight jumping in
you
I think we both have solid structures
this diagonal concerns me but
go here first
interesting break is it good
this pressure on that pond not easy to
defend you get that a to pond
no retreat square this night here maybe
I take here
all right there's rook there
I give this night a kick
feel it seems interesting try that
so what's the what's the big idea here
okay they're going there
take Oh take take take take
it should take I feel like I get some
nice pressure Bishop here
there
let's try this that's
to square I'm kind of
Keenen on Queen takes there's a
maintenance ret so
take the clean
do I have a trick here I'm gonna go here
least double isolated ponds at the
moment aren't so accessible I am on this
still am i winning that I gotta go here
I do get a pond no Bishop here first
faster
together hmm let's try this we're gonna
go hunting I guess
that's a nice move well done
you
I like that move a lot
hmm I like that move very nice
I take they're gonna unmask the rook
hitting my knight there
reposition my knight knight on d4 put
the knight on d4 oh I like there
better than my bishop
better than their works
okay
I'll go here I just
this night-night c4 move let's put the
knight in the center
I need a flight square more than my
opponent does let's go here got my
flight square let's go here no no let's
go here that's a big square I have
checks my bishops all in hitting the
Bishop and pawn and got to keep going
faster
keep going faster he says
I'm upon
and the night here I could take the
night
I almost know slipped or something
now slipped or something yes here
going
let's go here first training take the
would check that might be a really key
move maybe get the cleans off as well
or not
here
you
now know how to assess this one also my
time is not looking good
should I try and get the rooks off
Oh No
why did why did I oh my goodness does
this make it very easier what
ah that was a really bad really bad
decision
I mean should be a draw objectively but
is the wrong color bishop
or not
no it's not it's not a draw yeah oh that
was a tough one
mmm I I know I must have had something
there
fast and good
hmm
okay
and try this again it went well last
time
an early early win of the rook
I know I had something there I know I
had something
think I think I had something there
develop the queen-mother night could
still go in here
you
I don't know this is a sensitive valve
this is a sensitive point yeah
[Music]
I guess we'll take and enter a rook and
pawn ending which should just be even
I guess I'll go to V Batman
is the opponent
let's take here and then get a little
wild with the Queen
after go Queen here maybe I'm heading
I'm heading to
so I think queen c6 queen there
[Music]
he got the file
let's keep the Queen around for a minute
one minute I'm still keeping pressure
here
that's just advanced
so no longer pressure on c5 like a win
d5 this guy is fast fast and past
my rock
where's that clean goin
you
all right
um that move
you
okay
just drop every pond next time I should
really think about dropping upon more I
just dropped two ponds
you
[Music]
you
and I could get another one
my little trick I think is to yeah
they're just not even not allowing any
tricks
my king needs to be better
thank you safer here
you
keep pressure on a row
in this break
you
you
yeah they have all their bass points
covered what can I do
softening up my King side with h3 or h4
you
uh-huh I'm not sure I'm not sure I'm not
sure
you
I need my rock on G okay they're getting
stuff
I think it's a draw
time
you
you
yeah I have to try this
Queen there ooh
why did I why did I think I should keep
the cleans on in that one I'm not sure
poor poor endgame assessment to think
that clean should still be on
hmm
you
get the Queens on and try the
try the rook ending I guess
yeah also I could play a little faster
too not sure what my clock situation was
for that
for that moment
huh
okay that was a tough one
this will castle
you
take bishops kind of staring off into
space
let's put the Queen out here then I have
the knight around
Wow it's a really fast decision there
isn't it
seems like a really fast decision
the bishop here
let's go rook here first
yes the Queen's are coming up
that's how they're dealing with that
centralized
playing so fast
let's try here
you
hmm
I'm having flashbacks of the last game
where I just I'm running out of a steam
here
with things to attack
thing is to attack
to play some defense I guess
still need a flight square
you
oof
they could have just won that pond I
think
you
save this guy
so quick
you
try and get active on the kingside
and I go after g4
you
all their base points are covered
they push yep
you
I don't know how to make progress here
let's just repeat
they want more
okay I guess you get a point for that
I'm not sure I get a point for that one
point eight oh three is top six oh two
is not 602 is its way down
you
let's see we'll go for a six
all right I go hedgehog land keep the
night off as c6 you avoid an eventual
tactic once the rook is on see one night
jumping in on taking Pinter Oh knees
all right on Rocky
da torre 8 let's put the clean here
first let's get the flight squared
let's go opposite the Queen back the
bishop hop it's on an unprotected square
on e7 and now here we go what do we do
we break right now let's back up
first okay
maybe maybe this right now
you
all right we have action now where do we
go I could take I'm on this night it's
getting complicated so let's see what
can I do first let me maybe first take
this guy
now I have a check to work with
I have this I have this okay they're not
taking back that light square bishop
let's preserve it then aren't there
light squares weakened my dark squares
on the kingside are weakened but I at
least still have this guy around
take care night here jump night here
jump control this night I control the
bishop
the defending path I take here
just say I'm up upon
you
I guess Bishop has g7 now
I could get these two moves in I think
I'd be happy they're gonna kick they do
right away play some defense I have this
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
nice shot
and also this check here I didn't even
see
hmm
you
nice trick man nice trick I have to take
scary for sure
it's the body calm down upon
we have this as a resource to get the
cleans off
up a piece currently they're going to
take this night back or they think about
moving the night crashing through here
that is an idea
maybe
to take think I need to I need to get
the cleans off my King feels more
vulnerable so I'm on c4 at the end I
have the bishop hair can I not take this
though
let's give that a go it is one check
let's go here
stay out of night checks so this Bishop
doesn't even feel like feels like I
should be better even though I'm down
upon I'm on the night seventh-ranked
stuff I'm coordinated on a g2 so first
of all where they go with the night are
they going anywhere
they shouldn't because before can fall
you
and the tank
rook here
let's get here first
it's going to here first
let's grab a pond
that night moves whoa
okay first
hmm
I gotta get a checker Oni am I getting
mated I want these two moves in take the
pawn and then I should be able to give
me with these two but who's mating who
first
you
Bishop takes pawn rook
Jack King here night check and I'm gonna
knock I'm not getting made it I don't
think guy my bishop controls this square
here here and okay that
scaring me in the
to just say let's give this check maybe
we play on time
okay
check first they're being sneaky there
they wanted a fork
maybe I could be sneaky
maybe
time
everything grab this pawn
you
not defending everything
ah there we go
run
now stalemates
foof tough tough tough okay
53 minutes to go
let's see turtle turtle turtle turtle
it's got the pirate flag turtle turtles
in first for the team 39 is on fire as
well
okay
I felt like I should have fallen for
my opponent has something's something
pretty sweet there
I think they had something pretty sweet
you
love this event this is a very nice
event
and I'm getting the bishop pair or upon
I'm getting both
I'm getting the bishop pair and or upon
I guess
bishop they don't let's put some
pressure on their dark squares fast-fast
we can
[Music]
spot for this unopposed bishop than the
main diagonal
okay we're taking with the pawn this
might be a
us no no wait a second around this guy I
was on that last note too
I had enough
you
well it's just castle first
here here I move my clean they get this
pawn
you
let's go here
clean check to get that bishop off this
is their best piece so now my queen
could be challenged but I have this to
defend directly lab checks if rip III
broke a five still defending I'd go with
the check I got the check
and now I will take
struck here and it seems cozier maybe I
should have played age six or no I'm
probably better to first compete for
this file yeah now they it's a little
irritating no I'm okay with plying this
I week in dark squares but he's he's
cool
and I could go here
stop the main threat
I've made some weaknesses on my Kings
side but there's only one minor piece
and in this position I have one okay I
mean maybe this is what they have to try
just to stir up some trouble but it
should not be
should never be working
here here you get the
books
their options though
check burst okay taking first
a-five a half of this can they get to
this square I don't think so
but let's let's think maybe a bit more
aggressively
suppose I go here first
let's just go here
you
this is not the cleanest approach here
for sure I don't want to move with this
Bishop clean here would be bad news for
me
what if I take this pawn now
you
don't on the clock
remember what I was saying about this
let's not get there let's not let the
clean get here this is taken
I don't like my approach at all here can
I finally get my rooks doubled in
most there
think we're almost there completely
consolidating
get the cleans off push this pawn
you
you
almost have perfect coordination Queen
here first
26 seconds
Quinn goes too far
like that pond
threatening meat
yeah at this this point I feel like I'm
really close to just losing on time
really close
okay you get the cleans off
you
let's go
you
sure
another check
I'm a threat
I was on the rook
are they stopping mate though
broke right here
give a check first and then take the
rook
not a not a fan with my technique there
at all
bad really bad not not good at all
okay to be up upon like that and
have been better for sure too
much counterplay
when I sneak this one in there
but the bishop here take
play within this structure
support my night I think I should be
able to get that pawn back
let's go here so here
Bishop there okay it's a little
surprising I have this jump which is
nice I think this Knight has this square
I don't know how great it is though
let's go here
take with the pawn get this guy after
the knight has to run away also
threatening to take the knight and then
take the pawn bishop may back up I think
it's a little a little bit of an
inconvenience for my opponent attack
Sparrow
so some improving moves Queen d7 rook to
d8
let's do it
not winning a palm if they go in for
this they can't take with the night
because I get the fork still have enough
support for that let's centralize
maybe I could increase the pressure with
Queen Queen of five trying to force this
capture we have a
we could also still still go here
pressure on the night
maybe I just go back at night h4f here
okay that move
bishop here what am I really getting
getting myself in trouble
let's try this
my pieces feel more harmonious than my
opponents Oh
[Music]
you
I'm asking for trouble I
maybe back off
like a fly away and f5
I'm opposite the king as well
let's try this again both kind of
floundering
both of our nights are pretty good
spot
now
threat
King move maybe f2 is sensitive mist
Ivan
you
I think my queen could actually be quite
good she's on d3 hitting a lot of stuff
and the night here
yeah might get trapped
rook III was scaring me am I now ready
to dive in here
let's do this the rooks aren't as fast
to fight for the e-file Oh
interesting all right what if I take
here though I have a trick now
here with the check and they get the
night Brooke takes I could take like
this otherwise the queen is defending
this queen of forecheck
oh the rook can block and then there's
Queen takes here but I would have some
night check
like clean is now hitting a lot better
clean them up upon
how do you defend this night there it's
improved the night f2
two more
okay something fast
I have this the night at the pawn is
pinned let's just throw in a quick check
let's get back here on f2
maybe soften up the kingside keep going
keep going win this poem
we could liquidate so on King
unending
the king freeze these guys watch out for
sneakiness sneakiness
no sneakiness no stalemates
now stalemates
here
in there okay had some pressure
41 minutes to go
we're at 7 2016 total turtle turtle
having a very good tournament
there were 43 points donut Chaz 42
one with 42 as well
this is a this is a oh we get to see the
streaks - that's that's a nice feature
get to see who's on fire
okay
you
take my bishop and take with the queen
I think night right here okay so now
really close to grabbing some space okay
then allowing me to get an e for so
let's take the space right now now I'm
going to hold off actually
maybe centralize first keep some
flexibility with this pawn
yeah
this is a way to play it how long
this setup beam
now are we going for four night here
maybe now maybe now I grab this space
keep the knight out of here he's no
longer eyeing up c5 so a little patience
there
as black basically losing a a tempo or
two
we make for progress
you
well this Bishop for starters isn't
isn't so great well this is a newly open
file let's let's fight for it
you
right there I'm not quite sure what it's
doing this we get this always almost
always useful move in there okay they're
all I see what they're ready to do all
right we might have all major pieces
come off soon I think in the end though
I'm getting somewhere like actually
suppose I played this right now when the
night doesn't have this as a defense I
think this could be problematic this
Nets me some
this Nets me something now in this
ending
oh they could have maybe grabbed this
pawn my bishops now they're my Knights
ready to go somewhere else where is that
is here f4
Queen exchange
I guess I'm okay with that and let's
still play aggressive here
okay wolf I think they're Knights are
dead
I think my opponents nights are dead
there Bishop may be dead as well
there should be a way to stranglehold
the nights
I might want to start with this move
seems weird
I'm gonna do it though I want to stop
this break
we get this in improve my King and prove
my king first way down on the clock
over here they might target c4
okay let's come back here
you
ah yeah
I don't know I need
over this square
my nights are better than theirs but
they're still I don't know am I now
ready for this because there it wouldn't
be a five push if I could get in see
five think I'd like that
they're on my pond at the end I think
I'm still gonna go for it get this out
of the line of fire first see if I could
get my pond all the way up here
or at least establish a really strong
night post think they should take I
think they should take again all right
I'm going to go here
guy has his
no it's really far advanced
on b5 where's the ideal square for my
night maybe right here
can I can I make progress over here
it's a race
I'm getting some making some progress
with my king
love to have an outside passer if they
take like this I'll end up with an
outside passer I dunno I might I end up
with an outside pastor no matter what
now save the night tuck them in right
next to my king here still my opponent
has doubled up on the clock here
it's actually really clean if they if I
control this square I control the night
this is the only square for the night
okay the night's dead
victory is clear from here
really clear
defend this
and the night has under control this
pond is under control that it's night is
dead you just push through
okay
thirty five to go um okay don't have
time to look the cable boxes in there a
45 with fire I'm trying to I'm trying to
get level trying to get level with the
cable box yeah
the tactical one
very sharp player saw the cable box
playing
tournament just last night did really
well
let's be a little aggressive why not
take the pawn maybe exchange be pawns No
[Music]
you
let's go here with the bishop pair Ramon
in-betweener okay let's take here
see where that bishop wants to go I
guess now because I don't have this
resource anymore so the dive-in
very timely
this move is one that I almost missed I
think it's good I don't want to see some
smooth you know Knight takes bishop
takes a really nice deployment for the
bishop and then the rook this Bishop I'm
looking to control that guy let's get on
the main diagonal
file
might dance again Knight f3 maybe I go
here hitting the bishop
yes
I have some space so that's the other
you know the other idea I want to maybe
keep some pieces around and I think I
want to take this and now the structure
has changed at a point where this pawn
is not around too easily start
contributing and I think I begin with
this have some nice space and they just
drop their Bishop
they're going to play on
maybe out of momentum
centralized
night
ever want that
it's nothing too long
now
we want to think about them getting some
some G file play let's just blast it
open
take that pond I'll take this pond
you
take this night
take care taking advantage of a pin
Knight takes here I just want to
simplify
you
okay go wrong with this this move
scrap this poem
you
defend my back rank
now you take here next they are up on
the clock up a night in a couple ponds
okay you get some work
Changez
or some material actually here hitting
the rook and the Queen now
we try to get rook
night for the Queen
but
No
you
you
there
just want to get out of the pin getting
one works
in there which is going to make life a
lot easier for me
all right now they resigned
huh one night 1093 team chest network is
in 10th
8:09 we're fishing we're fishing for
nine
okay let's see
let's try c6 we still got 30 minutes to
go
we'll take
and play here
let's go with this capture
less-experienced with it
okay
I guess a clean exchange
bishop here
like this guy before nod and play this
guy before
stands with the night
Bishop c4 95
it's the bull rating
simply bullet
I does all about I get away with winning
that pond
probably know
what about now
probably not
now I'm probably threatening it alright
let's straighten out the structure
C 4 OC 4
tonight
right now we could secure them
it's some play on the h-file if we can
have some space it's way over here on
the on the queenside but
I have jumps as well my nights on light
let's look at two rooks if they're ever
on light there can be a four Corona
keep on pushing
I like this idea and one
further or do I try to cement a night
into this square I think I like this
idea this smooth
and then a knight here should be really
really good
we'll see
also conveniently defends East six which
could be a sore spot this is this is
soon to be my weakest square mmm I cover
this base point my King conveniently in
the center on a dark okay
that's interesting alright so now maybe
I don't even have to
[Music]
worry so much about my Jeep on ho
take with the king dodge a check
a step-over now we're prepared to fight
on the e-file with what rook probably
I guess this one maybe something
exciting happens over here
let's go let's go here and
for this
I I'd like to keep one rook on the board
I don't know if that's if I'm going to
be able to manage that
maybe they're gonna have to play c3
that's surprising okay an interesting
post so now I don't think they can get
two rooks off how do I make progress
though
hmm not easy my night needs to do
something else
you
your rook takes rook takes I have this
check
have this but I'm there first okay so
that's that's big news
that's a structural change I feel like
my king should be the safer I have a a
sneaky guy
checks I have pressure here
let's go here look for this stuff I
think this is maybe a nice a nice move
no I'm not saying what's what file I'm
going to just yet
what about this check and then moving my
night where though
hmm want to go for this
Eric has this timely tempo but but the
time the time tempo thirty-nine each
it to pigs
so going to be enough
let's cover my base point keep this rook
here need some defense
okay get that rook off
sir my pong quality my pawns are further
advanced their King I get to promote
with check
a king is cut off
you
time time time
you
ah
you
my time
oh my goodness it is me oh that got too
close oh oh
way too close called us a berserk game
my opponents berserk me
okay I can use some more experience here
with this opening
back off bishop up for scaring me
be aggressive a bit more excited about
and playing h5 when the Kings opposite
my rook so
see what happens
Aldous is bulla rating
2771
clean exchange I'm happy with
all right
I could take the bishop with check this
is a key detail so the yz5 may have been
something yeah that's what they're
setting up now so my bishop probably has
to go to a safe square or I have to
reposition my knight
you
nah throw them in the corner I thought
about this as well
voiding e5
I have this is a trick
let's just trippin science
keep going here
yeah now this with tempo maybe alright
you
wouldn't mind getting g5 in there this
that's weekend let's see it feels slow
but queens aren't off okay let's let's
let's try this idea rook is active my
Knights are swarming and now I could
have considered grabbing that pawn
let's go here defend - I'm on this now
this
defending that
okay let's just come all the way back I
thought about that
steak yeah this night is very annoying
they resigned keeping pressure on that
the queenside
the pocket
let's go with D 421 and change remaining
let's still go with this
[Music]
it's kind of like a maybe a bit of a pet
system
I go with ya normally normally I do
something to stop I I play h3 to stop
that bishop from being a pest
um it's not so easy to get out of this
pin I don't know if I want to play this
move so
mmm let's go here first this could be an
idea
it's castle alright they're playing in
the center
let's go here first if I do this
eventually there's a hook and this gets
ripped open and I'm inviting the rook to
coordinate on f3 this I'm not concerned
about because my knight eventually if he
could get there in time on c4 and
normally he can he has a nice death grip
over the the the Queen side maybe I just
have to play this move or I come over
here
they're just immediately out of that
that pin I can also step up
with that what about
now let's step up
you
just realizing here I can't take twice
just yet okay
you
[Music]
about this and then too far-fetched
actually have a part on f3 to neutralize
the bishop
for it
this is a move
yeah
you
probably asking for trouble
you
keep this square open for my bishop
my nights dead
their bishop isn't so great but I mind
my knight isn't isn't so great I need to
I need to focus on improving this Knight
as soon as possible
love a dark square bishop exchange night
here
this pond is kind of overextended for
right now my minor pieces control the
Queen from attacking it on the
fifth-ranked - the night is
repositioning
Kyah
let's go here
this is a plan right now I'm gonna go
for it I guess
other night is is defending the bish up
to know h5
okay hi it's getting sharp
oh if I take like this then there's this
move nice the night is unprotected
here there's rook takes let's take that
Knight isn't budging
no no I think I'm toast yeah
you
this is tough
I don't know
as night takes
yes
it's over the Queen's gonna crash
through there I'm not in time I'm Way
off with
getting 2h7 16 minutes remaining I
wanted that one
okay this is another a berserker
armed chess player five is having a very
good
a very good result for the team cable
box is right on my heels
this that Bishop move
now I'll go to g5
take try this again where I'm not not
fighting
light-square bishop
stay here for a bit
go for a night maneuver night on c4 c4
b6
go for
here I could take the night thinking
initially I have to go to g6
clay
you
so on this I could take
a knight there right away let's put
immediate pressure on the night now
let's go here first and now here I'm not
sure why that mover why that move order
exactly maybe get aggressive with this
guy
now let's try this
okay they're just just coming right at
me here
on d6 with the fork take care
I'm just going to take everything take
with the night
Fork isn't going anywhere I don't think
I'm taking with the night as well
because why I want to be able to kick
this night away guess we banked the
material flush this night back
and now improve the clean where exactly
here if I go to f3 night here's a bit
annoying so
offering a draw what oh they wanted to
resign okay who fast pairing 14 to go
still
let's go at c5
five e6
a six and then d5 advance let's see how
they react to that okay
like I like my position
you
okay
[Music]
here
I want to stop the knight from jumping
in if I can
I know I've taken a couple Tempe whoa
running right into that Queen stat roof
that was a Miss the Queen was cooked
13 in change
Maya 57
I get another
- in
looking for a a PB trying to get a PB I
think
let's play aggressive
pressure if we can in the center on the
dark squares
let's go @d h vh pun
look for addy for break I don't know if
I want to Castle queenside I think this
is going to be my home
all right not sure what the queen is up
to they're going to go clean side
let's just go here
all right
let's put this rook here
g4
to stay
trained
opposite the king
and after this I'm
on the night go forward or just return
all righty
okay yeah this breaks okay break some
stuff and they were just going to have
an ending huh
I'm just going to lose a palm
you
that queen is their best piece for sure
in this position she is doing a
fantastic job and I just blended this
palm
yep that's a gonner
gotta go
don't know if it's the end of the world
I've still this dar square
are also clean here
take here I am on the Oh the clink it
taken beyond the night
okay let's take first
I want to go
yes here is this
I there any great checks for my opponent
tonight is a little offsides very timely
more about finding some sharp moves okay
so
take the night take the pawn with check
the King has to go here
I'm gonna go right back and invest it
first
and now some timely move
check here
thrown this check first
and then recapture Queens necessary on
c5
what about this check
and then here get out of the pin and
defending this so now I'm ready oh they
get the Queen's off
technical phase where it's now balanced
and it's going
upon quality akira most blundered my
rook immediately ascending
save it
save it for the time being right there
let's go
defend my pawn
check my King enters their king is cut
off and I haven't had much time
going into a pin
we go here if there's a night check
do I
they're setting up tricks
they're setting up tricks there
you
you
hmm somehow up upon what
on the clock
you
like here I have a fork
ah
Knight is in the corner oh I gave that
check
you
you
right here
you
oh boy
you
mmm draw ugly ending a tough ending with
those nights whoo all right this is
probably going to be the last one for
this tournament
try to go out on a good note stop be
five castles
you
they're getting that in now then I guess
we have to babysit a couple ponds
let's get out of Penn
let's go here the Queen isn't around for
those little tricks on h4
let's go in
on d6 I'm on h6 this is basically an
intolerable night
Oh
well my clean can't stick around here
forever trying to defend b2 so
my knight was here this kind of
sacrifice
is more tempting
so it takes this is a nice tempo to get
and I think I want to stop
yeah let's get the night here for
starters I want to stop a central break
these guys would just love to have that
my king does not like being here anymore
so let's get out of there
I don't mind I like seeing this move so
I guess they're gonna sacrifice
okay if they're going to sacrifice the
sacrifice I think they need to
Wow
my bishop is fantastic they could remove
it
but this is this this shields the
pressure on my c2 pond
right
this why not sure okay queen queen g4 I
had in mind of challenging the night
when it gets to have four I should be
thinking more about g3 though
you
so we take now here I'm on the night
that night is pesky let's remove it
it take here if Knight takes Knight
go here
first
they could have played
could have maybe played
you
I don't know
hmm
I'm going to put pressure on this
yeah I got I got to get rid this night
got to get rid of them
f7
three minutes remaining
okay
gotta go
you
my king I think needs to take a walk
you
maybe not put my rock enough to first
you
catch them in a pre move it's being a
little sneaky there
are you even going to be allowed to get
over here clean here
Oh Freight mi of that okay I don't know
where do I go from here
G for break No
this check
and here looking for this break
thank the
stage is set for something on the G file
now that I've evacuated my my king
you
and try this
on the rook this Oh
got a sneak in there somehow
any position like oh there on that roof
you
my only hope is a pre move they're gonna
get me there
I could only have given one check anyhow
and after a king here I didn't have any
good follow-ups mmm
yeah that night's gonna be too good I
think a defender I think also back to
tournament they're closed
oh we could still get nine somebody win
Oh somebody want I finally get to look
at the team standings fishing for night
fishing for a ninth I'm in a hundred
that's not gonna stand for these next 29
seconds
go go go who's in a game make it check
out a somebody who's playing
not seeing anybody playing
battle for ninth or tenth oh we got a
four somebody got a four
ten-nine oh we gonna get 9th or 10th I
[Laughter]
see in the chat come on nine
we get it somebody won again I think
they're closed oh we had a good stretch
there I think a couple wins at the end
yeah
Oh with the Penguins there was a really
nice battle up here for top penguin
first is to our event three Oh chess
1373 1356 1331 top three
whoa
very nice results and I am just outside
of 100 land a 101st overall
event
very nice good games to all teams
not gonna I guess we could go through
the top 100
let's see the top 100 there you go with
the first-place guy Matthew G p4p
scoring 108
oper only losing two games
performance is that performance rating
of 27:32 top dog
number two is what
/ 2780
mastic results
alright that is your page one
let's see let's see the top 100 then
we'll have a look at the top 100 overall
and then the top
top players from team chest Network
so
you
we're getting there it's it's shifting
on me
you
Oh
here we go
all right that's your top 100
I ended up
one hundred and first very nice turnout
seven thousand one hundred and
twenty-two are in there let's see the
standings here for the team
whoa chess very nice result 67 armed
chess player 67 as well I got in their
third 59 the cable box
58 58 and you can see the top there's
Popovic what's going on Popovic I
haven't looked at the chat at all I see
you there now
you
seven polish Mozart is in there two more
two four seven sincerity rules Houdini
Ivanka valenko has played many times as
well
you jur Amir netsky dolna chess orbit
Ickx adrenaline Vishal three zero to
nine Napoleon bellow Agito
Ferro
GOx are the top 20 and see the top 50
though I'd go through everybody that was
on the team
had that list but it only shows the top
50 so congrats to all who competed I
hope you enjoyed the event these two
hours always seem to fly by
a great competition for sure
you